i was married to a man more than 20
years my senior
and when i first started looking around
i thought i only like older men i've
only always liked older men there's a
certain
confidence that comes with age with
maturity for both women and men
continue
oh my god
just keep on going you've always liked
older men
these older men got with you because you
were younger
now that you're older they're not gonna
go for you
they're gonna go for younger
that's it
so basically
you were at the spot where where you
wanted
wanted you back
but now you evolve
dear pokemon
all right
and
you got to the point where
what you want doesn't want you anymore
it's rough to complain about
some [ __ ] that she like that's you
but
it's not just it was her it's still her
she still likes old romance yes so to me
there's something funny about
complaining about ages and it's like
your own dating taste is you
discriminating based off that's exactly
what you're doing
you you're you're pissed off because
people are not dating older women but
you
date it's okay you get do you get what
the [ __ ] is going on here sometimes
sometimes we have like this like what
appears to be like but it's just like
the audacity of something yeah
you know i'm not mad that there's some
older women out there who are struggling
with that's fine that's normal and
that's okay that you want to date older
people oh there's nothing wrong you know
i can be sympathetic to the fact that as
you get older dating gets more difficult
i understand that what's distasteful to
me about this story say it she's
actively having these dating standards
and then saying let's change society
about the dating standards that i myself
[Music]
will you not even do you're not even
changing your dating standards you're
talking about oh i'm i've been my inner
divine feminine i feel so sexy i feel so
in control yet you still need these age
gaps but you want everybody to change
for you
but you don't
rather than the enthusiasm of youth i've
had a few young ones contact me and uh
and it's been fun
right now i'm sort of dating in all age
categories except for anything that
approaches my son's age that would
that's just that
no no thanks why not
that's a form of ageism right there yeah
yeah hold up hold up you want anything
that's approaching your son's age boo
boo when you got with your husband you
did he was dating somebody
okay all right
here's the thing
here's the thing go ahead
we all know this is [ __ ]
i don't care what aisle you stand for i
don't care if you're a geriatric woman
you know living the nurse i don't care
what the [ __ ] is happening in your life
we all know this is [ __ ] this is
some [ __ ] this is literally in-cell
talking points when someone sits up here
and says i feel invisible we should
change society the way that we view
looks and beauty
right that aging shouldn't be viewed as
this thing that's like for old folks and
that we should be seen as attractive why
it says who says who
hmm that's what that's how insults talk
that's
literally the vocabulary
i'm an involuntary celibate
so my father is damn
no i'm saying she's as extreme as them
with what she said but it's the same
same angle it's the same addiction it's
the same is the same category different
degree not the same degree same water
though exactly
not the same depth the same pool exactly
you in the shallow wind they're the
deepest yeah well it's the same pool so
to me i hear this stuff and
and what gets to me is not the fact that
she's even saying it's like everybody
acts like yeah you go girl yes queen
it's like what okay so when she
struggles yeah we should change society
and the way that we view old folks and
you know what there's real forms of
ageism out there i feel like there's
ways in which we discard our elderly i i
think are nefarious in terms of our
society
but it's the whole thing that you're
supposed to be seen as attractive or
valuable or great looking it's like
whether you're an old man or an older
woman it's like yeah we start discarding
people after a certain age that's a
reality for both genders i don't think
we have to center it on beauty i feel
like that's like the most vapid and
shallow way to look at ageism within our
society that we're still talking about
people's looks so the one thing that
will guarantee fade with time is the
thing that we are axed on in terms of
wrinkles on the bottom of this stuff
it's like okay
this is why i don't advocate for like
fighting aging at all costs and fighting
the way it looks on your skin and
fighting the way it looks on your face
it's like you know past a certain age we
shouldn't be valued for the way that you
look it's perfectly acceptable to get to
a certain point and i hope you have so
much more to offer people that people
can appreciate those things you know
when we have mentors or we have good
teachers we have good principals we have
good leaders within our community who
are older we're not looking like oh my
god that person's so beautiful no those
are folks who have a lot to offer their
communities and do so in a way that's
meaningful i don't give a [ __ ] if you
still look like 40 at 55 like who gives
a [ __ ]
what can you contribute to the people
around you that's what you should be
doing right
imagine natives they go like yeah this
is the this is the elder of our society
damn she's sexy like that's not the
point why you have hell different if you
get older fuzzy if you get older and you
look good
good
but
that's not so much the point that's not
this shouldn't be your goal it's like
yeah that person look good yeah they
look good next
next you don't think that's easy for you
to say
because the fact that let's say i'm a 50
year old woman who became single through
no fault of my own let's say my husband
passes et cetera et cetera
now i feel like i've been aging i'm
trying to fight that process because i
know how hard it is in the dating market
if you don't look great
you don't think that they're dealt a
tough hit peep game i'm more like
if they say you see like a 54
55 or 60 year old
person yeah they look good
454
which is fine
like let's say i'm gonna be in that
dating pool i'm dating rem whatever what
not
i'm not gonna look for that person to
look [ __ ] look like a 20 year old
that's not my jam
i also want the person that looked like
a 50 60 70 whatever but well maintained
you see that
you kind of see that there's kind of a
beauty in it but it's not like
there's difference between beauty and
sexy you know what i mean
beauty is some other [ __ ] sexy is one
thing that i believe is really according
to being
young i mean if you look at betty baddy
winkle maddie winkle there's a beauty in
the way that she's youthful but she's
not sexy
she's not sexy there's a beauty of how
she carries herself and she doesn't give
a [ __ ] and she smokes her blunts and
she's out there with her outfit that's
not sexy
but that's beautiful that's facts so if
i'm out there and i'm her age and i'll
be like yo batty wink will be a little
oldie belly you know what i mean only
betty she she you know you gotta get
wrong whatever betty winklebee no d
betty
freddy [ __ ] od
she could be all of that she could be
you know she could be nice she can y'all
she i'll be like yo she's fun to be
around i don't want to have a hag around
me all the time i want to have someone
that's beautiful you want a baddie
winkle i want a batty winkle body winkle
living with her wrinkles the way that
she moves she had betty so she know it
never tell her to stop the way she batty
bad bad
tell her to stop the way she wrinkle
rank rad
betty baddy winkle go batty batty boo it
doesn't matter if she's fat if she got
boom boom boom boom bones bones
tell me what you
[Music]
that's what it is so there's a diff
there's a difference so if you're 15
50 60 whatever you still can be
beautiful i'm not looking asleep for
sexy i mean it's fine if you have it cuz
i've seen some 50 60 70 year old yeah
seven year old being sexy but that that
that's
something else you know i mean they
are not the norm you understand what i'm
saying so let me say this
just because you feel sexy just it
doesn't mean you are yeah you can say
loud you give me like oh yes me and my
you know listen
if you look like a tails tails of the
[ __ ] keeper it's okay to not look sexy
you can still be beautiful in your own
way okay
that's fine you can look
you can look congratulations you can
feel sexist you want doesn't mean you
are and that's okay
you know i'm sorry
you don't get to choose who sexuals now
no more just grow older that's that's
just grow old embrace it
it's time for you fade in your sunset
let the new generation come all right
doesn't mean you can't enjoy your
process but like trying to hold on for
dear life
to like the past it's like rough it's
okay to age that's a stigma that we got
to remove
you know what i'm saying it's gonna
happen like i said everybody wants to
extend their summer as long as possible
yeah
it's okay fall is a beautiful season
right you see the trees they start to
turn orange on the leaves as they start
falling to the floor you start to feel
the temperature change the weight folks
it's okay it's a beautiful season not
everybody's it's not summer not even
yeah not everybody's going to stay in
summer and fall is beautiful and you
know where there's even some beauty in
death
remember i said last video she's not
invisible she's invisible to the men
that she wants yeah she approved her
right there she got young dudes old
dudes trying to holla at her i told you
guys she's not invisible that's just a
[ __ ] cry for attention okay
she didn't like the suitors she got that
doesn't mean that there's a problem with
society we have to change it that's
crazy to me
sanders are [ __ ] up talk about
invisible talk about you're [ __ ]
dramatic
invisible
you're not you're not invisible i told
you and i'll tell you guys this again a
lot of people complain about their
dating prospects
it's not that they don't have any they
don't like the ones that they have well
maybe your issues your standards okay
that's one and two
marrying an older dude the dude who's 20
years your senior you know has its
benefits the dude has stability in his
life he's got his finances his home his
prestige in order it's great right
you're walking into a situation where
the castle's already built and you're
just moving it
right security that's fantastic
but when he's 20 years or senior i'm not
surprised that he dies
when you're in your 50s
but that's what you married into you
married into comfort right
and there's a beautiful thing in that
i'm not mad at you you should be
attracted to that that's for you cool in
your life but you chose that now you're
much later on in life
sad that you didn't get experience your
summer to its fullest degree
you could have married someone your age
you guys could have grown old together
much more likely right
but you chose that comfort security so
at some point we also have to
understand these decisions that we make
when these guys who are 30 years and
senior the woman get married to a young
woman then these guys get to 80 the
woman's out banging other dudes or they
end up leaving him he's like well
do you think you guys were going to stay
in the same realm your whole lives
you know what i'm saying
what do you think was going to happen in
that same token a lot of people who
marry folks their own age struggle
together right the finances come hard a
lot of the struggles come together at
the same time because none of you are
like in your best years in terms of
having all that security in your life
every type of relationship has its pros
and its cons what i cannot stand however
and this is the big thing you say you
like a certain thing everyone's like go
do go do your thing
you enjoy the prom pros then the cons
come along you want a refund
you know what i'm saying
right it's like
right you wanted to buy a chocolate cake
then you mad when you get a tummy ache
later
it was delicious while you were eating
it now you want a refund because you're
two things
you get what i'm saying like that's what
i don't understand in this and sometimes
people are like yo you guys are mean
that you guys could be more
i just i just want people
people deserve some level of empathy let
me say very first i can understand i
want to give people a certain level of
empathy but when you don't take
accountability for the choices that you
make when you don't own up to the fact
that the things that you did help
contribute to your situation i start to
lose a lot of that because then
everything is always everyone else's
problem and for folks who don't want to
do self-reflection realize like how did
i [ __ ] up in this situation i just i
have a hard time taking an injury uh
listen lady you're still in your summer
you're actually still in your summer
it's just that now you have to put some
sunscreen on to i don't know maybe a hat
some shades
to profit
you got to change something you got to
change your standards but you're still
in your summer you could still be in
your summer you're like oh my god you
pulled up you pulled a leaf out of a
tree and you call it fall no you're
being dramatic you're still in your
summer all right for the agents you have
you're still in your summer put some put
some cream on go outside just go outside
and play
what do you guys think what do you think
we're missing about the whole ageism
discussion if anything let us know in
the comments below